in this video today we will discuss
about how godzilla got his powers and
whether the other members of the gojira
species in the past like dagon had
similar characteristics
or if godzilla of the monster verse was
the only one with them
we all know that the big g wasn't the
only one of its kind but was a part of a
bigger super species
but he is the last member of his kind
due to the fact that many of the others
had been killed
in a war with the kongs or the mutos so
did the present godzilla survive due to
his unique powers
and that the others died due to the lack
of them
well that question will be dwelt in
deeper in this video
so subscribe if you haven't and now
let's get down with this sickness
so firstly let's start with what are
godzilla's powers
though technically a reptile and not an
amphibian godzilla has an amphibious
lifestyle however
he spends half of his life in water and
the other on underground layers or on
land
which makes him an adept combatant in
both environments
a bionuclear circulatory system gives
godzilla his strength
the neutron flux is generated when
godzilla is threatened and it travels up
the dorsal
spines to the nuclear synthetic chambers
in his throat where it explodes into his
atomic breath
godzilla feeds on nuclear radiation and
can sustain himself for millions of
years at a time by
absorbing geothermal radiation from the
earth's core
or maybe from the hollow earth this
nuclear biology of his gives him
a signature powers that he utilizes in
battle against other titans
in godzilla 2014 godzilla's atomic
breath was more of a focused fiery
shaped energy beam that
godzilla spears out like a dragon in
godzilla awakening and godzilla king of
the monsters
godzilla's atomic breath is far more
powerful and intense and
seems to be like a beam like an
appearance implying that his breath is
not at full power
in godzilla 2014 and can even be
stronger when
he is in better conditions in godzilla
vs kong
godzilla's breath has grown even more
powerful to the point that it can bore a
hole to the hollow earth
then we also have his thermal nuclear
pulse which is like a controlled nuclear
explosion
that can vaporize anything in the blast
radius
so how did he get his powers since the
very first incarnation of godzilla in
1954
the big g has had the ability to shoot
out his atomic breath
and it comes out naturally for him but
in the most verse there is a story from
the eewee people on how the big g got
these powers
and this turned him evil so the story
goes like this
in the novelization of god's love versus
come there was a conversation between
eileen andrews and jia regarding kong
and their history
although she was deaf she could still
tell the tale passed down by her people
through thousands of years
through sign language and also spelling
out phonetically that is just speaking
out
without knowing what sound comes out
from your mouth basically
and it all revolves around an ancient
eternal enemy which they call the zozla
halawa
which is bad lizard which means that the
name is also a reference to godzilla
well the story goes like this zozla
halawa
lived in the long ago below like calm
like us he ate a star there and made him
evil he could throw rays of a star out
of his mouth and burn things
so it was decided that he could no
longer live and the long ago below
ewi and gong made born a friendship i
become one people to
fight zozla halawa they fought for a
long time
trying to make him leave but something
went wrong i think
someone broke a taboo maybe anyway comb
and evie travel together in darkness
until they reach the surface
and reach the light of this place we all
left the bad people behind and as those
la halawa
with this stomach star too there was
peace for a while but
some monsters followed us skull crawlers
and some others
and calm parents fought them so did gong
so we can easily see in this paragraph
from the novelization that
it was a reference to the ancient fight
between gongs and the gujiras
so godzilla had to eat something that
gave him his abilities
the atomic breath which was described as
a race of stars shooting out from his
mouth
godzilla became the alpha titan as a
result of his newfound abilities
and began his ascent to the top of the
food chain so will godzilla get more
powers in the sequels if he is ever
to make a comeback to the monsterverse
well there is the spiral heat ray that
he hasn't displayed yet
and maybe the flying with the atomic
breath and the magnetic abilities
who knows maybe but anyway in the story
it says that godzilla
got his powers by eating something maybe
it was the energy source from the hollow
earth
anyway what about dagon and the other
gojiras as a member of the same species
daegon shared many physical traits with
godzilla
this includes jagged dorsal plates a
dark coarse skin
yellow eyes gills wide feet a robot's
head and short forearms and also a long
long tail dagon faced and fought with
the muter prime in the year 1100 bce
the mutual prime batted dagon to death
near death
after a brief skirmish then implanted
her eggs into
dagon's stomach lining before burrowing
underground
so if daegon had the atomic breath and
nuclear pulse
it would have been a longer battle and
not just a short fight as described
especially when we saw godzilla fight
with the muta prime quite a number of
times
over the course of 2014 and not just a
short fight
and in the end godzilla kills demeter
prime so this gives us a hint that maybe
dagon and the others did not have the
unique powers that godzilla has
maybe the godzira species like the other
titan species had no special powers
aside from being
super big and durable this would make
sense as the other titans even rodan had
no special beam attacks
or flaming breaths cilla had liquid
nitrogen but that's just a result of her
metabolism
behemoth gave life because of his poop
and it's just the mirrors that had the
emp which is said that they developed to
counter godzilla's powers
and this points out to another direction
so what do you think
i'll let you guys decide in the comments
section so subscribe if you haven't
and hit that bell button for regular
updates on new master content
right here on minecube till the next one
take care fam